Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
« La Terre, notre vaisseau. »
Pour moi, c’est une citation
de l’inspirant architecte, inventeur,
écrivain, futuriste, Buckminster Fuller.
« Il n’y a pas de passagers
sur le Vaisseau spatial Terre,
seulement un équipage.
Et la chose la plus importante
au sujet de ce vaisseau spatial,
c’est qu’il a été livré
sans mode d’emploi. »
Il m’a fallu du temps pour apprécier
la richesse de la métaphore de Fuller,
qui exprimait en peu de mots quelque chose
qui parle aux scientifiques,
qui parle aux politiques,
qui parle à nous tous.
Ma contribution aujourd’hui,
ce sera de tâcher de vous convaincre
que cette citation, vous devez la placer
au cœur de votre action dès aujourd’hui.
Et d’abord, réfléchissez
à ce vaisseau singulier,
sans mode d’emploi, ni destination.
La destination, c’est peut-être
le futur qu’on espère de progrès ;
Le mode d’emploi,
ce sont peut-être les sciences
dont on attend des clés
et des procédures sûres,
comme doivent l’être les procédures
dans un vaisseau spatial.
Et puis pensez à cet équipage.
L’équipage, ce ne sont pas
seulement les personnes
que nous élisons démocratiquement
pour les mettre aux manettes
et que nous remplaçons régulièrement.
L’équipage, c’est aussi
chacun, chacune de nous
parce que notre comportement collectif
influence la trajectoire du vaisseau.
À bord du vaisseau, quand on regarde par
le hublot, on voit des choses inouïes :
des astres nouveaux,
des phénomènes inattendus.
Parfois, avec beaucoup d’imagination
et de réflexion, on peut les anticiper.
Les formes géométriques
qui composent la matière,
les réactions atomiques, les trous noirs,
les liens de parenté
qui unissent tous les êtres vivants,
l’usage de la génétique et l’épigénétique
dans la médecine,
les algorithmes qui créent de nouveaux
mondes logiques et graphiques,
tout cela, il a fallu beaucoup
d’imagination aux passagers,
aux scientifiques, aux rêveurs,
pour les accomplir.
Aujourd’hui, des chercheurs travaillent
à rendre la vue à des aveugles,
à créer des voitures
qui roulent toutes seules,
à extraire de l’énergie
avec des cerfs-volants.
C’est un monde de magie
transformée en réalité.
Après tout,
comme le disait Arthur C. Clarke,
« toute technologie suffisamment avancée
est indiscernable de la magie. »
Ici, le vaisseau spatial
touche au sublime.
Et pourtant, les scientifiques sont loin
d’être unanimes sur cet univers, ce futur,
dans lequel, peut-être loin
d’être un monde enchanteur,
où les robots travaillent à notre place,
où la médecine nous protège des maladies,
où les divertissements
technologiques nous enchantent,
peut-être c’est bien plus sombre.
Écoutez les scientifiques du GIEC,
comme Valérie Masson-Delmotte,
grande figure de notre plateau de Saclay,
écoutez les scientifiques
de la biodiversité de l’IPBES.
Ce qu’ils nous décrivent, c’est plutôt
une prophétie de désolation :
un monde déstabilisé
par le dérèglement climatique,
un monde en lutte
pour la possession de l’eau
et des ressources premières
qui se raréfient,
un monde en guerre mondiale peut-être
sur fond de destruction des paysages
et d’extinction des espèces.
Ils nous montrent les courbes de
concentration de CO2 dans l’atmosphère
telles qu’elles sont enregistrées
dans les archives du monde,
les microscopiques bulles
des glaces de l’Antarctique.
Et voyez,
nous constatons que ces courbes s’affolent
maintenant comme jamais depuis 800 000 ans
et toute notre précieuse technologie sera
incapable de remettre le vaisseau spatial
dans la bonne direction
s’il n’y a pas de changement de
comportement de ses passagers-équipage.
Il nous montre l'évolution de la biomasse.
Et nous constatons que nous nous sommes
accaparé le monde vivant.
Les êtres humains, les animaux
domestiques et ceux d’élevage,
aujourd’hui, ça représente plus de 96 %
de la masse des vertébrés terrestres.
Et les quatre maigres
pourcents qui restent,
c’est à cela que nous avons
réduit toute la faune sauvage
qui peuplait les rêves de nos ancêtres
des grottes de Lascaux ou Chauvet.
Voici les courbes de la pollution
dans le monde.
Nous constatons qu’elles augmentent
exponentiellement,
à l’image de la production
de plastique encore aujourd’hui.
Progrès scientifiques réalisés
par de brillants esprits
mais pas toujours de bon conseil.
Certes, les connaissances
s’accroissent inexorablement,
mais l’usage qu’on en fait peut être
parfois nuisible, parfois une régression.
Songez que le DDT, le plastique
ont valu des prix Nobel
à leurs inventeurs.
Aujourd’hui, ils sont des symboles
de pollution et de mort.
Que dire de cet objet familier
qu’est la voiture ?
Quand j’étais gamin,
j’avais un ouvrage passionnant
sur toutes les innovations
qui constituent une automobile.
Passionnant, certes,
mais quarante ans plus tard,
il faut se rendre à l’évidence :
l’humanité semble incapable de se sevrer
des ravages causés par l’usage massif,
incontrôlé, de l’automobile.
Même en mathématiques,
la seule science où
les énoncés sont vrais pour l’éternité,
il arrive que l’on revoie sa copie, que
des raisonnements tombent en désuétude,
que des théories passent de mode.
Moi-même, j’ai passé beaucoup d’énergie
à redémontrer par d’autres voies
ce qui était déjà connu,
dédaignant les méthodes de compacité
qui avaient rendu célèbre
mon directeur de thèse,
rejetant explicitement l’axiome du choix,
dont on nous expliquait à une époque
que c’était la meilleure façon
de construire des objets mathématiques,
convaincu que dans ce domaine
comme dans d’autres,
souvent, le progrès n’est pas dans
l’invention d’outils plus sophistiqués,
mais dans l’agencement harmonieux
d’ingrédients élémentaires.
Que dire de l’économie ?
Parfois aussi,
on fait fausse route, peut-être ?
À l’ouverture des
Jeux olympiques de Londres,
était célébré en grande pompe
ce qui était annoncé
comme le plus grand événement
de l’histoire de l’humanité :
la révolution industrielle,
initiée outre-Manche au 18e siècle.
Aujourd’hui,
pour les défenseurs du climat,
c’est peut-être elle
qui contenait en germe
la déstabilisation
que nous vivons aujourd’hui.
Cette révolution qui venait
avec cette surproduction
et surexploitation
des ressources premières.
Et pour l’agriculture, il y a
quelques décennies, le progrès,
c’était l’agriculture intensive,
plus productive.
Aujourd’hui, pour ceux qui aiment
le vivant et le sensible,
ce sont les pires pratiques
en matière d’agriculture et d’élevage.
Hé oui ! le mode d’emploi
n’a pas été livré.
Nous nous retrouvons aussi aujourd’hui
dans une situation délicate,
comme avec cette épée de Damoclès
suspendue au-dessus de la tête.
Elle ne tient qu’à un fil et ça dépendra
de notre comportement collectif
de savoir si nous allons
conjurer cette épée
ou bien si elle va fendre
le vaisseau spatial.
Alors, dans ces conditions,
que faire ? Quel choix ?
Si on est scientifique, c’est difficile,
si on est politique, encore plus.
Il y a 50 ans - 50 ans déjà - un homme
d’État américain, Adlai Stevenson,
a déclaré, approfondissant la métaphore
du vaisseau spatial :
«Nous sommes préservés de l’anéantissement
seulement par le soin, le travail,
et oserai-je dire l’amour que nous offrons
à notre fragile vaisseau spatial. »
Citation inspirante
à la lumière de laquelle
on peut lire le devoir
de la personnalité politique aujourd’hui.
Et d’abord, se tenir au courant
de l’état de l’art scientifique.
La science souvent hésite et parfois
ne fournit pas la bonne solution,
mais qu’est-ce que nous avons de mieux ?
C’est la tâche que j’ai tenté d’accomplir
à travers diverses institutions,
à la charnière entre
scientifique et politique.
Aujourd’hui, je préside
l’Office parlementaire scientifique
au sein du Parlement français.
Nos derniers rapports portent sur la
recherche polaire, la pollution plastique,
les nouvelles techniques de modification
génétique pour les plantes,
les traitements contre le Covid,
l’intégrité scientifique,
l’efficacité de l’hydrogène,
ou encore les phages -
qui sont les virus des bactéries -
toutes sortes de sujets
sur lesquels il est important
que les scientifiques puissent
éclairer la démocratie.
Un autre devoir du politique,
c’est de travailler à la manœuvrabilité
du vaisseau.
Qu’il soit souple, indépendant.
Pour moi, c’est le sens
de la construction européenne,
une échelle de débat
et d’action politique indispensable,
mais qui ne deviendra une réalité efficace
que quand elle sera un vrai espace
de débats, de discussions, d’échanges,
entre ses citoyens et les institutions.
Devoir du politique, c’est encore,
encore et toujours aujourd’hui,
d’affirmer et de se reposer sur l’amour
que nous devons offrir
à notre vaisseau spatial,
notre fragile Terre
aujourd’hui tellement menacée.
Le devoir du politique, c’est de vérifier
que tous les passagers sont à bord
et de bien vérifier qu’ils sont
conscients de leurs responsabilités,
de leurs responsabilités
de membres d’équipage,
car notre empreinte sur la Terre dépendra
pas seulement des choix collectifs,
mais aussi de nos choix individuels.
Si vous êtes un citoyen conscient
de sa santé, conscient du vivant,
soucieux d’en finir avec les pesticides,
avec le martyre des animaux
dans l’élevage intensif,
alors la bonne nouvelle,
c’est que c’est possible,
que des chercheurs y travaillent,
à l’INRAE, au CNRS, à l’IDDRI,
et que ça viendra certainement
non pas par l’utilisation
d’outils très sophistiqués,
mais par l’agencement harmonieux
d’ingrédients élémentaires.
Et ça sera un grand chambardement.
Ça viendra avec une productivité moindre
et des marges à revoir.
La biodiversité le vaut bien.
Ça viendra avec
des chamboulements économiques.
Nos éleveurs, nos agriculteurs
le valent bien,
eux qui sont aujourd’hui
exploités par le système.
Avec des changements
d’habitudes des consommateurs
et ça ne pourra pas se faire sans.
La cible, c’est une réduction,
une division par deux au moins
de la consommation de viande,
c’est l’une des conditions.
Il faut se souvenir :
ce sont des choix individuels
à faire en cohérence.
C’est un chemin que j’ai accompli -
je suis devenu végétarien sur le tard -
par cohérence
avec mes engagements politiques.
Et dites-le-vous bien,
si vous ne faites pas ce chemin,
n’attendez pas que le politique
résolve le problème pour vous.
Il ne peut pas le faire sans l’équipage.
Et d’ailleurs,
tous ceux qui veulent ne pas bouger
seront trop contents d’exploiter les
incohérences du comportement des citoyens
entre leurs souhaits, leurs aspirations,
et leur comportement devant une publicité
ou leur comportement de consommateur.
Si vous êtes un entrepreneur
attaché à son pays,
un ingénieur fier de son savoir-faire,
et que vous vous désolez
du retard économique
dans la haute technologie,
dans l’IA, dans l’algorithmique,
pris par notre continent sur d’autres,
alors dites-vous bien :
la solution, elle passe aussi par vous.
Si vous attendez que le politique
résolve le problème,
vous ferez partie du problème.
Vous devez être le changement
que vous souhaitez.
Et ça veut dire faire confiance
à nos ingénieurs,
à nos écoles, à nos laboratoires,
embaucher, prendre des risques avec eux,
leur faire confiance.
Et c’est mieux ainsi.
Que ce soit dans le domaine technologique
ou dans le domaine politique,
on jouit vraiment des changements
que l’on sait mobiliser pour avoir,
qu’on a su conquérir.
Les femmes n’auraient peut-être
toujours pas le droit de vote
si elles s’étaient mobilisées un jour sans
attendre le renouvellement de l’équipage,
sans craindre les moqueries de la société.
Alors, c’est simple,
faites passer le mot d’ordre :
l’équipage, c’est nous.
Le mode d’emploi, personne ne le connaît,
mais il s’agit de faire au mieux.
Et compte tenu des grands périls,
du cap à trouver dans l’obscurité
pour le vaisseau,
de l’épée de Damoclès à conjurer,
message à tout l’équipage :
nous avons besoin de vous
toutes et tous, maintenant,
sur le pont, avec vos talents
et vos compétences propres.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)